now it feels like I've read this
introduction a few times before but
Teresa may was back in Brussels this
week as she tries to find a solution to
the issue of the Irish backstop donning
streak had hoped to put a new deal to
Parliament this week but now that's
looking increasingly unlikely
so is there away through joining us now
from Cork is Ireland's Deputy Prime
Minister Simon Cove me thank you very
much for being with us on the show this
morning thanks Sophie now this weekend
three members of the cabinet signaled
that they would prefer to vote for a
delay to article 15 extension to article
50 and a delay to brexit if there's no
agreement that is reached now of course
we know how much a No Deal could impact
Ireland so is this a move that you
welcome look I mean I think I need to be
careful not to get into the politics of
Westminster but I mean we do know that
that the Parliament has already voted
against a No Deal in principle at least
and so you know we'll have to wait and
see what happens on Wednesday whether
there is a new amendment that comes
forward to try to take no deal off the
table but look you know I've said this
week very strongly that everybody loses
in a no deal situation Britain loses
Ireland loses the EU loses I don't think
anybody can make the case sensibly for
an unmanaged no deal breakers in terms
of the impact that that would have on
all of our countries but look where we
want to be in the next few weeks is with
a deal a managed controlled exits from
the European Union for the UK moving
into a transition period which gives
gives everybody the time and space to
adjust to the new realities to put in
place what we hope will be the closest
possible future relationship between
Britain and the EU and of course Britain
and Ireland and we've been working
towards that for for three years now
that is why we supported the withdrawal
agreement at the end of last year and
that's why we supported the Prime
Minister in terms of the compromises
that the EU had to make and that the UK
had to make to get that withdrawal
agreement
agreed between the governments of course
we're now at a process of ratification
both in the European Parliament and in
the British Parliament that's proven
very difficult for the Prime Minister
and she continues those efforts again
this week but from an Irish perspective
you know our position is clear we want a
future relationship that is controlled
and managed we want the closest possible
relationship with Britain that Britain
is willing to negotiate but there are
some issues and some flexibilities that
Ireland's can't show particularly after
a deal has been done on the withdrawal
agreement and that is that we can't
undermine a peace process and the island
of Ireland north and south we have to
ensure that the commitments that have
been given by the British government and
the Prime Minister to provide guarantees
around an absence of physical border
infrastructure between the two
jurisdictions on the island of Ireland
that those commitments are followed
through on so that we don't see border
infrastructure having the kind of
corrosive impact on relationships on the
island of Ireland that takes us
backwards rather than forwards and I
think that has been a very consistent
message coming from Ireland over the
last three years and indeed very much
backed up by the EU and also supported
by the British prime minister so we have
to find a way now of getting that done
and the EU has been very clear that we
can't reopen the withdrawal agreement
for that to be renegotiated or changed
and so we are in the space of trying to
provide reassurance and clarification
for the British Parliament to allow them
to to ratify this deal and to reassure
them that actually this so-called
backstop which has had so much to base
both in Ireland and Britain and across
the EU doesn't represent a threat to
anybody in fact it's quite the opposite
it's providing a fallback insurance
mechanism in case the negotiations don't
result in a resolution of this border
issue that this is a temporary insurance
mechanism that can take effect while we
put in place a more permanent solution
between the UK and British negotiators
and the British government let's talk
the backstop challenge because it does
seem as if Teresa may has put all her
eggs in one basket which is to try and
get some kind of movement on the
backstop to try and make sure that
enough conservative MPs vote for the
deal just how do you say that that there
is no reopening of the withdrawal
agreement so what exactly is on the
table because clearly if you say that
you don't want a No Deal there's gonna
have to be some kind of movement on the
backstop if Teresa may is going to get
this deal passed around back benches
what's up for grabs yeah but I think
it's important to understand and for
British viewers to understand that this
isn't just about Westminster this is the
deal that has to get through a European
Parliament as well 3:28 negotiation yes
yes it does if if Britain wants to to
get a deal and avoid a No Deal and
that's why we wanted to get through
Westminster but you can't ask Ireland to
compromise on something as fundamental
as a peace process and relationships
linked to the Good Friday Agreement in
order to get a deal true which is about
placating a group within the
Conservative Party who were insisting on
moving the Prime Minister away from her
own position so to be clear then Sophie
it's important
just to be clear Sophie because I think
it's important that people understand
this the back stop was a British
government construct as it was an EU or
an Irish government construct this is
this is about a shared responsibility
for Britain and Ireland as Co guarantors
of a peace agreement in Northern Ireland
to ensure that we don't go backwards
that we don't as an unintended
consequence of Briggs's see the
re-emergence of physical border
infrastructure between two jurisdictions
a border infrastructure that in the past
has had awful memories and so we have
said for two years now
Ireland has said look we need to provide
a guarantee here to people living in
border counties north and south on the
island of Ireland that whatever happens
in breaks us they're not going to face
if
single border infrastructure again and
the security infrastructure that would
be needed to to facilitate that that
surely is not an unreasonable request
and so because then of British red lines
around leaving the Customs Union leaving
the single market as well as leaving the
European Union we had to design a way of
providing those guarantees and
reassurance that is legally sound and
the idea now that you would put a time
limit on a backstop in other words if we
can't negotiate a solution on the border
through the future relationship and the
backstop kicks in and the temporary
basis that we would put a time limit to
that backstop but not be able to answer
the question what happens after that
time limit runs out and what replaces
the backstop then it wouldn't be a
backstop at all no time limit on the
backstop no no but we are we are open
and we always how about a unilateral
exit mechanism sorry I mean you're doing
the job now for lobbyists in the UK with
respect sorry the it's been very clearly
the the red lines from an EU perspective
not just an Irish perspective are very
clear the withdrawal agreement is not up
for renegotiation the withdrawal the
withdrawal agreement wording is not
going to change and so what the space
that we are in here is to try to provide
reassurance to a majority of people
hopefully in Westminster that the
backstop is temporary that we're going
to try to avoid using the backstop at
all because it is only an insurance
mechanism nobody wants to use it not in
Dublin not in London not in Brussels but
if it is used because we don't have
other alternative arrangements that can
do the job of the backstop then it'll be
it'll be in place for a temporary period
of time unless and until we can replace
us with alternative arrangements that
can do that job and we are open to that
the problem is that we haven't found any
other alternative arrangements it took
two years to to agree on and the British
government helped to design this to
agree on the backstop model and so when
other people talk about or
of arrangements that can work most of
those solutions have already been tested
and they haven't stood up to scrutiny
and so we're what we're saying is if
there are alternative arrangements that
work and do the same job in other words
providing guarantees that no physical
border infrastructure will be needed
between the two jurisdictions well then
they can replace the backstop in time
and that's catered far in the withdrawal
agreement text already where alternative
arrangements are referred to it's
catered for in the future relationship
text already and so what we're saying is
that the withdrawal agreement legal text
is finally balanced it's a series of
compromises from the EU as well as the
UK and if you start opening that now
other EU countries will start to look
for changes in wording to suit them as
well okay and so the way to do this is
to change the wording of the future
relationship declaration that can help
to provide more clarity and reassurance
to Westminster and if necessary to build
on the clarification and reassurance
that people like president tusk and
president Juncker and Michele Barney
have already offered but except that we
need to try to do more so we want to try
to help the Prime Minister and indeed
the British Parliament find a majority
to vote to vote for and support and
ratify a withdrawal agreement like Hayes
don't ask Ireland to undermine something
so fundamental as a peace process that
we should all be protecting